good evening welcome to Washington on my
command you illan for bret baier
president Trump is urging Americans to
strive to be worthy of the sacrifice of
the country's fallen military heroes and
on this Memorial Day the president and
his team are actively engaged in trying
to reduce the chance of war and what
could be the world's most dangerous
neighborhood we'll have a report from
the Korean Peninsula in a moment first
Tonight correspondent Kevin cork is at
the White House
good evening Kevin evening my game is
solemn memorial day for the president 1
punctuated by speeches songs and of
course heartfelt salutes for the folks
who paid the ultimate price in serving
our country and defending our freedom it
was also a day of full of new questions
about a brewing spying scandal that
threatens to overrun the DOJ and the FBI
we are gathered here on the sacred soil
of Arlington National Cemetery to honor
the lives and deeds of America's
greatest heroes the men and women who
laid down their lives for our freedom
in marking the second Memorial Day of
his presidency President Trump today
called on all Americans to never forget
the sacrifice of fallen US service
members saying they shared a love more
deep and more pure than most will ever
know
among the many veterans in the audience
today 94 year old Bob Dole former Kansas
senator who spent nearly four decades in
Congress and was wounded in combat in
World War two and received a thunderous
ovation from the gathering
but while the president's meant this
Memorial Day honoring the memories of
the Fallen both on hallowed ground and
online he began it by focusing his
attention to a discussion on Fox News on
so-called spy gate and the idea that the
FBI placed an informant into or around
the Trump campaign during and after the
2016 election on Twitter mr. Trump
quoted constitutional legal scholar
Jonathan Turley who told Fox that the
president deserves some answers said
eval stood acting AG Sally Yates I find
her actions to be really quite
unbelievable and said if the Obama
administration put the opposing
campaigns presidential candidate or his
campaign under investigation and that
raises legitimate questions adding it
goes to the heart of our electoral
system we should get everyone involved
in get them on the record and get that
record to the public because at some
point we're gonna have to come back
together as a country this division is
getting deeper and it's because
politicians on both sides are playing
games with these investigations while
New York Democratic Senator Chuck
Schumer noted in a tweet the mulher
investigations 19 indictments and three
guilty pleas he failed to mention that
there's been no evidence of Russian
collusion uncovered by the special
counsel who may not if the president's
lawyers have their way get an
opportunity to interview the president
in the Russia probe and the reality is
we're not going to sit him down if this
is a trap for perjury and until what
convinced of that
and if they don't show us these
documents well we just gonna have to say
no Giuliani says the president insists
he wants to sit down with the special
counsel in fact he said as much on the
record Mike but it's also important to
point out that his
at least for now or advising against it
Mike Kevin Cork leading us off on the
North Lawn Kevin
many thanks